j'ai trouvé ici à tour une justice en
grande souffrance en grande souffrance
avec un certain nombre de magistrats de
greffiers qui ont souhaité me rencontrer
pour relayer
relayer le cri de détresse qui a été
poussé par les rédacteurs d'une lettre
qui a été signé par sept mille magistrat
et ses cris d' alerte des magistrats de
terrain ont été reliés vous le savez par
le procureur général de la cour de
cassation monsieur moulin lors de la
rentrée solennelle de la cour de
cassation et face à cette détresse qui
s'exprime en la justice eh bien nous
avons un garde des sceaux qui préfèrent
regarder ailleurs il a crié au scandale
il préfère museler la justice plutôt que
de la sauver les français vivent un
constat d'impunité on a moins de 5% des
faits qui sont dénoncés qui donne lieu à
une condamnation la justice est noyé il
y a deux millions de français qui sont
en attente de jugement et les délais
judiciaires sont aujourd'hui compris
entre 18 mois et 2 ans
alors la justice et malgré elle devenue
le maillon faible de la chaîne de
sécurité du pays mais parce qu'elle a
été abandonnée depuis dix ans elle n'est
évidemment par responsable la france
dépense deux fois moins pour sa justice
que l'allemagne là encore emmanuel
macron n'a pas tenu ses promesses il
laisse notre système judiciaire dans un
état désastreux seulement 2000 places de
prison ont été construites sur les 15000
promise seulement 20 centres éducatifs
fermés ont été créés sur les 56 promis
je veux faire de ma présidence celle de
l'impunité zéro et pour ce faire je vais
très en place un plan de sauvetage et de
modernisation de la justice un plan au
long cours un plan sur cinq ans qui
redonnera les moyens à l'autorité
judiciaire de juger vite et bien qui
simplifiera et accéléra nos procédures
pour mieux protéger les victimes et je
le dis il faudra mettre en place une
vraie commission de réécriture du code
pénal mais aussi sans doute en partie de
la procédure civile
et qui adaptera le droit à la réalité de
la délinquance